natural selection chooses among
self-replicating entities those
self-replicating entities have some kind
of power over their probability of being
copied of being replicated to being
passed on in practice that almost always
means choosing between alternative DNA
genes so it's about the natural
selection the disproportionate it's
about the unequal survival of genes
through generations that is natural
selection we see it in the form of
changes in phenotypes that's to say
changes in bodies because it's through
the changes in the bodies that the genes
induce that they ensure their survival
or fail to survive the ones that are
good at surviving are the ones that are
good at building bodies that are good at
surviving and reproducing
we're G machines in the sense that a
body is constructed by genes that have
been successful in surviving in the past
they're good at surviving because
they're good at constructing machines in
which they survive so a body is a
machine for the propagation of the genes
that built it